we are very excited about our next guest
a new member of the viacom cbs family
longtime tv news anchor natalie morales
takes on a new role today as the newest
co-host of the talk she joins cheryl
underwood amanda kloots jerry o'connell
and my guy akbar bajabia miller former
nfl player now she joins on cbs daytime
talk show uh mirage leafs after nbc
being there for more than two decades
having worked on the today show access
hollywood and dateline natalie morales
joins us right now from los angeles good
morning natalie how are you doing yeah
i'm doing great nate how are you guys
we are good we are good so what are you
excited about most joining this new show
well i'm excited really about the cast
that i get to join i mean this is an
incredible crew i've spent the last week
kind of getting to know them
i love that there's now some male
perspective on our panel we've got jerry
and akbar your man as you said who i
just absolutely adore both of them and
amanda and cheryl are just the complete
picture of a great team so and being
able to talk about important issues of
the day even if it is the great peanut
butter and jelly debate which i will
resolve this for you too much jelly
makes the bread very soggy we all know
that right
that's true
so natalie you you've guest hosted
before how did this come about did you
reach out to them and say you know
i'm kind of interested or did your phone
ring one day and you picked it up and
they said hey we'd like you to come what
what drew you to the job
it was a total i was in tokyo when this
happened the phone rang and this
opportunity just came out of the blue
it was the chance of a lifetime i felt
and um you know couldn't say no to an
incredible opportunity and especially
with this renewed energy around this
team at the talk i really felt like it
was the right time to do something
different after the year and a half that
we've all been through with the pandemic
being home a little bit more with my
family was important to me as well and
this was an opportunity to kind of
ground myself here in los angeles so why
not
hey natalie this is we every day we we
realize that this is an extraordinary
moment to have an uh two hours of live
television in your case an hour of live
television every day there's a lot going
on in the country of the co-host there
you have the big news background uh how
and will you bring that to the table
when you start today
yeah
well you know i think with my 20 plus
years in journalism and by the way gail
and i go way back to our days in
connecticut together we were competing
morning anchors i'd just like to bring
that up gail
i was going to say we were not at the
same station but i definitely knew who
natalie morales was
definitely knew you
yes i was on the nbc side you were there
cbs side so um you know i do believe
that my role is to help moderate and
guide the discussion especially
involving stories that are perhaps more
topical and newsier stories of the day
and to make sure the facts are out there
and presented but also you know i hope
to have a seriously good time with this
cast
well listen there's no doubt that you
can handle this job you've certainly got
the experience but it is still a big
change for you natalie the day-to-day
but i have no doubt that you will kill
this job but what do you say to other
people who are thinking about making big
changes in their life this is a big one
for you
yeah you know and i've done this before
moving out here to los angeles was
taking a big risk
i do believe though that you know life
is too short life is sweet and we've all
learned that in the last you know couple
of months it's been hard for a lot of
people and i think the opportunities
when they present themselves sometimes
you know
those are the best challenges in life is
when you get a chance to prove yourself
in a different way and that's what i'm
here for i'm game for anything
well talk about being game for anything
first show today what are you guys
planning can you say and how are you
feeling because i remember when i came
to cbs
i i was nervous but it wasn't a nerves
about could i do it because i always
thought i could do it i just wanted to
do it knock it out of the park and that
gives you a different kind of nerves if
you know what i mean it's because you
care so much you just want to do a good
job so i'm wondering how you're feeling
as you're about to start this new
chapter and what to expect today
yeah
exactly as you said it gail you know
there there was certainly some nerves
last night even just going to bed this
past week i haven't slept all that much
because
it is such a big opportunity and i feel
like there is a weight a little bit on
my shoulders to you know to really
deliver but it is that
pressure that i am self-imposing to try
to do my very best and just wanting to
live up to expectations
but i am so looking forward to it and i
know i've got you know this incredible
cast that i'm i'm i'm not alone at the
table by any means this is going to be a
great adventure that we're all taking
together so i'm looking very much
looking forward to that
oh natalie we have twin adventures going
on you know twin adventures we're not at
the table alone and i like it i like it
she's preaching to the choir
preaching to the choir let the church
say amen natalie morales cheering you on
cheering you on always thank you thank
you so much
we'll see you at two o'clock you can
watch natalie on the talk weekends at
two o'clock eastern one o'clock central
and pacific right here on cbs